hi everyone welcome back to house of
cards I'm sorry time Jessica got such a
good game back with a really good game I
reckon this is a scariest game that's
ever been on house for us
I actually think so like it is famously
the only game I've had a massive
freaking I'm live on stream much to my
embarrassment yeah so we're going to
revisit it of course yeah playing dread
outs today which we decided down before
and she's armed only with a camera
camera so it's fatal frame this is what
I wanted you guys to hear this is it
it's so happy in that it's so menacing
what it's very nice wow really
okay I wouldn't go that way that's that
shoes oh yeah dangerous oh yeah this is
a good idea let's all do this a lot of
the ghosts and I guess monsters you
encounter in this game are based off on
Indonesian creepy like folklore tales
and myths and creepy stories when the
edges of your screen gets blurry so if
you can see I'm getting a blue one right
now it's an indication for you to take a
photo or something yeah oh yeah a
soldier's middle is that it was that
that was from the glare oh cool so it's
an indicator
we used to hang out on an elementary
school okay that's it looks like when we
used to sit on you can sit on it again
Oh memories this is the weirdest
friendship ever
ha ha ha you guys didn't notice my work
uh pitch black
no no no not necessary you know what
they're probably fine you should just go
back oh oh good everyone's fine here we
go here we go yeah um what's your like
what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ] [ __ ] we
really started no oh no oh no oh no oh
no oh no oh no oh no oh no oh no
why do you learn wait how did you get
everyone let it get away from here what
are you doing you idiot shut them yet
yet probably not
oh [ __ ]
oh yes [ __ ] course both balls balls
balls oh [ __ ] me [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] I think we need to look at it
in our camera and I don't want to
costume something go into a classroom I
think seriously is there anything
creepier than that shut the [ __ ] up
uh no yeah I didn't think the pictures
gonna help with him stupid pigs dad peg
I swear to go he's doing way too much
time a house of horrors running from
pigs
Oh God Amy TV take an open door now what
what a little pinky
oh yeah you're dead so we just have to
get close enough and take what is that
this is unnecessary attention noises
piggy piggy piggy piggy hey go away
yeah why are you away Nicky what I think
was I think I think there's a good thing
to pick up thumping I don't know but
it's thumping it's close it's a good
idea balls
no oh noes
oh this just can't be good no no it's
another people
it's another Pig I didn't Lisa that's
not a pig man that's not a pig man shut
the [ __ ] face that jump don't jump
turn chung-kai taking photos keep Jesse
photos photos photos photos I'm doing a
man I am taking phone
have we got to take photos see we're
gonna take more photos I am I am I am
okay she's jumping us again he's behind
us again she's behind you okay so
Terrell there you go that's how you
[ __ ] doing you [ __ ] [ __ ]
picture you're still around oh wait no
prostitute in life she was murdered by a
jealous patron nice backstory you as the
supernatural being she appears as a
woman white with a hole in her backside
I don't like that room you don't like
this room I don't like any of the rooms
actually Oh kitty
hello seriously oh there there Ziegler
uh-oh you will never take my baby and
then in it the closet door is locked
okay
why is someone gonna bust out of the
closet at me I should have said that
yeah yes I think back up yes let's get
to me there you go oh [ __ ]
I love the caption there's something
about this picture I don't know
[ __ ] chicks oh jeez okay she's doing
that thing again
oh [ __ ] what's that in the corner oh
[ __ ] oh please don't please go away
Naval prostitutes take breaks in savings
nope nope nope nope nope nope
no I'm out hmm cool a ring or am I just
taking random possessions that used to
belong to now dead people I seem to be
very happy about it
oh yeah manbearpig shoot him like one of
your french pigs Oh what that's good
I kind of don't want to yeah thank you
for those seriously
[ __ ] pants we go in there I'm not going
in there you go in there [ __ ] [ __ ]
ass bull bull bull
she's got scissors she's got scissors
don't look just angle it looks like he's
getting behind you
oh now oh [ __ ] oh oh my god please don't
chop please don't cha don't cha turn
around turn around
anyway anyway I don't know I'm confused
I think she's on your left I don't know
now
oh she's still there no she moved I'm
not sure maybe she's behind you there
she is brilliant
saying yes little wings oh I could sure
I could try you gave it the old college
try
oh she's janky Jesus please die you
[ __ ]
why would she die why won't she go on
no nope nope no who we took so long with
this bus fight that the track had two
really good stuff
that's what happened oh
what the Bulls just happened that was
the strangest this chicks just like oh
okay good night oh we can cut it this is
when Serena and I work at the same
frequency now I can cut the keys off the
neck I was like oh graphical glitch all
right
it's demon from the other dimension keep
snoring stay way you up to you you piggy
like a pig
look up paint no we did it we got
something else boy change des again hey
no ghost you know that's a ghost right
in the in the volume in the that's
probably a ghost sheesh no not not lead
just nothing is fine Lucas I think you
know she's not behind this at all I
loved it willing let me take a picture
of you I'd say let me [ __ ] kill you
can we leave Oh take a picture she seems
to have our soul she's sucking my brain
the way
yeah oh we should move stairway
it'll be same one girl left
unless yes
shut up lady you've got the wrong Linda
no yeah
is it all good woman yes don't do it
again
oh dear this is getting worse oh oh oh
my things are backwards my back and my
great my forward is back and my back is
okay this is it again okay so you just
got to pop in and go left so right that
way and that oh you got a sure did god
dammit door escape
break it down oh really
but the bowl
this should be on you waving with great
I went into the belly of the beast
that was drain out it is available in
steam if you wish to pick that up for
yourself although I don't see why not
I mean why you would could we just play
through the whole thing but well I mean
but that's only the first bit yes there
the game will continue on with further
acts DLC yeah um so next week they'll be
about the game there'll be another game
but just will be out next week I am out
next week um I will have either dan o ed
come in in my stead thanks for joining
us it was good fun to get through a
complete game again and then yeah
thanks thank you very much for everyone
who join us let us know what you thought
in the comments below and they had a
digital happiness for flagging this game
show us so try out if you are an indie
developer and you'd like us to try other
horror games let us know you can get in
touch with either of us on Twitter on
Facebook or on what else do we have that
is that all of it carrier pigeon
everything's good alright well rock on
kids yep bye everyone